TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
coming to you once again from
the YouTube Space in Tokyo.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We're rolling out
Developer Preview 3
with the final Android O APIs,
the latest system images,
and an update to
Android Studio to help
you get ready for the consumer
release later in the summer.
If you've already enrolled
your device in the Android Beta
program, you'll
receive an update
to Developer Preview 3 shortly.
To make your app
compatible with Android O
and enhance it with Android
O features and APIs,
check out the post.
Developer Preview 1 of
the Play Billing Library
is now available.
This library aims to simplify
the development process
when you want to make
money through your app
without having to deal with all
the different types of payment
methods.
For the intro video and
a link to the CodeLab,
head on over to the post.
reCAPTCHA is now available
as an Android API
as part of Google Play services.
It uses our newest invisible
reCAPTCHA technology,
which runs risk analysis
behind the scenes
and has enabled
millions of human users
to pass through with
zero click every day.
Head on over to the
post to learn more about
how to integrate the
reCAPTCHA Android API.
Blockly is our
open source library
for creating the block-based
coding experiences,
and we're now finalizing
the 1.0 release of Blockly
on Android and iOS.
These versions have everything
you need to use Blockly
natively in your mobile app.
To get started, a video and
all the links are on the post.
The latest set of improvements
to the Firebase Dynamic Links
are now available in our
iOS and Android SDKs.
They enable you to create
user-to-user sharing campaigns
programmatically
from within your app,
and a rebuilt Android
API makes it easier
to handle incoming
dynamic links.
Example code is on the post.
You can now manage both
your custom domains
and SSL certificates using
the new beta features
of the Admin API and G
Cloud command line tool.
These new beta features
provide improved management,
including the ability to
automate mapping domains
and uploading SSL certificates.
Example commands
are on the post.
Spinnaker 1.0 is now available.
It's an open source,
multi-Cloud, continuous
delivery platform
used in production
at companies like Netflix,
Waze, Target, and Cloudera.
There's also a new
open source command
line interface
tool called Halyard
that makes it easy to
deploy Spinnaker itself.
To learn what Spinnaker can
do for your own software
development processes,
take a look at the post.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer Show"
from Tokyo.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]